I think you can make jokes about
anything but you have to accept that
there will be people who don't like it
and they are completely within your
their rights just as you are completely
within your rights to say whatever you
want to say they're within their rights
to react how they're going to react so
you can't be surprised or insulted if
someone doesn't like a thing you said
that is a contra that you you know
you're making jokes on a controversial
topic I think there's a lot of people
who court that and they want that
because it's its attention it gets more
eyeballs on them and what they're doing
but there's some people who do feign
outrage at this or they're genuinely
feeling like how dare you tell me what I
can and cannot joke about but I would
say in most cases audiences are not
telling them you can't joke about this
what they are saying is that wasn't
funny and that's a different thing I
think you can talk about any topic and I
think you can make any topic funny
it depends on what your point is and
where you're coming from audiences
always know they always know and if you
have a sound point that you're making
and it's well thought out and it's well
crafted you can make me laugh at a thing
that I think is tragic you can make me
laugh at a thing that I think is
horrific
you can make me laugh at a thing that
affects me personally but if you've done
your homework and you've gone about it
the right way it will still be funny but
it's when people do I think a lazy job
at something they're not trying as hard
as they could or they really are just
courting outrage that's when audience to
say that wasn't funny but I think it's
so rare it's so rare that anyone says
you're not allowed to joke about that
taste change over the years
and so topics that were routinely joked
about years ago that might affect
certain people maybe it's something that
happened to someone and we throw a word
around because it's a it's a shocking
punchline it's good for a laugh but is
it worth it and over time people who are
tired of being ashamed because a thing
happened to them they vote with their
silence or they say that's not funny and
I think that comedians have to recognize
that humor revolves and times change and
you can't stay stuck in the same place
for too long because then you're
irrelevant and so it's very easy to say
oh people are too uptight now they're
too uptight but the fact of the matter
is these people are the people of today
and you might be a person of yesterday
if you can't adjust and you can't be in
tune with what people think is is funny
anymore I don't think I've ever said
anything where an audience turned on me
in that way
I've said things that now I wish I
hadn't said because times have changed
and like the me of 15-20 years ago made
a joke that I wouldn't make today
because I just because I look at the
world differently now you know and
because the world is different now and
you know it's all part of a maturation
process I think for everybody and I am
of the school that says adapt or die you
know and so if this is not a thing that
we joke about anymore I'm gonna find
something else to joke about hour or
hour I'm gonna I'm going to be better at
handling these subjects so that people
know what my intent is my intent is not
to mock the victim here it's not to mock
the little person I'm ridiculing
something that is worthy of ridicule and
that every word out of my mouth is worth
saying
and you know just not to be cheap I
think is is a tiny thing but it's it's
kind of important